hey what's going on YouTube this is
actually going to be my very last vlog I
just found out that um it's the end of
the world sorry you must be out your
mother
[Music]
Oh what's going on YouTube oh my god
apparently it's the end of the earth as
we speak according to my knowledge the
world was supposed to end roughly about
a week or so ago maybe about two weeks
ago around the 21st didn't happen did it
which really got me to think for those
of you who actually believed it was the
end of the world do you feel kind of
stupid because you should Mitch I
actually asked somebody if they actually
believed that the rapture was coming and
this is how the conversation went down
no joke yo man did you hear that the
rapture was coming yo word dinosaurs are
coming back
oh you mean Raptor if the world is gonna
end soon I hope it takes this full out
first people of the earth let's think
about this for a second okay if the
world was close to end supposedly on May
21st at 6 p.m.
how do you know which 6 p.m. it is you
know time because are 6 p.m. in the
United States is not the same as the one
in China or Africa so India's right all
across the world it's all different
because honestly if people in Asia
believe that stuff - they must be
confused as hell happen
I read that people actually gave away
all their money all that skrilla the day
before the rapture was supposed to
happen by giving your money to charity
right before the end of the world what
does that do do you think you pulled a
fast one on God right before you bout to
die I'm gonna say it right now for this
video camera so all y'all can see we are
not gonna disappear on 2012 it's not
gonna be the end of the world oh no
David did you hear the Mayan calendar
ends on 2012 so you're telling me that a
whole bunch of people from a crapload
years ago that are now extinct like the
dinosaur
knows when the world's gonna end but
they couldn't predict when they were
gonna disappear does that make sense to
you huh I'm supposed to believe people
that thought scary white people on
horses were gods knew when the world was
gonna end do you know what normal people
do when we see that [ __ ] we run
remember y2k people the year 2000 when
the world was supposed to end and it
but Godzilla was supposed to come and
swipe your babies in your women is that
right so relax people and I know what
you're gonna say Oh on 2012 watch the
world's gonna end David and you're gonna
be embarrassed all over YouTube no I
won't you know why cuz you're going down
with me [ __ ] oh it's recording only
Asian people Park like this maybe if I
turn this way
perfect
[Music]